[Music]
5 26 into Monday morning we got a
follow-up to a recent viewer email about
the bumpy ride on the 95 515 between
Eastern and Charleston
last month viewer Craig asked if there
was any information about the 100 or so
speed bumps in the left lanes of both
directions on the freeway Nevada
Department of Transportation spokesman
Justin Hopkins said at the time that the
original rumble strips were raised above
the concrete grade well now Hopkins says
Engineers have come up with a solution
that they had Crews do some special
grinding so you be the judge what do you
think
certainly feels like a smoother ride
there and less bumpiness Hopkins says is
going to be repaving in that area this
fall Craig thanks again for that
original email buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone join the
driving you crazy conversation at
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com